jay we want you to think about the
sacrifices that you've made in your life
to get you to this moment right now
right here today
what are those sacrifices
how many years would you say
that's been oh
i would say that
i would honestly say that
i've probably sacrificed
most of my life
in
pursuit of this
uh i'm single
don't have a girlfriend don't have any
kids
and i look at all of my friends
some of the friends that i mentioned
earlier from college and everything
they've got beautiful families
your lovely kids
great careers
nice homes
and those are things that i think i
sometimes think that
i might have
if i
hadn't
been pursuing screenwriting
as hard as as i've been
um i think that i probably just would
have maybe done something else
but
settled into
like you know that nice normal career
and have
you know the home and the the family and
everything like that
another thing
is
family you know like my sisters my
nieces and nephews
i didn't really
go back to memphis often
to visit once i left i mean i tried
every once in a while but you know i
felt that this is what i've got to do
this is
you know
this is what i'm pursuing and and one of
my sisters even told me that she had
that she had this discussion with with
the other siblings that
jay's dream is bigger than
the rest of us and he's got to chase
that
and when she told me that she had that
discussion it made me feel a bit guilty
you know because
she's right in that i have kind of
ignored them for this bigger dream
uh it's something that i'm i'm working
on you know i'm trying to see family a
lot more
um
you just make that time to to really
live a life outside of the pursuit
because i don't want to
achieve success
one day and then
not have anyone
to share it with
you know whether we're talking about
a romantic relationship or whether we're
just talking about family
my parents have passed away
and one of my sisters passed away
recently and
i sometimes yeah do feel guilty it's
like i've been chasing this and maybe i
should have spent more time
with them
so okay
you know and i i honor that and and i
can understand how you might feel that
way what if you know you talked about
being an outcast what if not everybody
is meant
and and is really cut out for i mean you
know just because someone has the quote
normal life and nine to five job and the
trappings of success
doesn't mean they don't have other like
creative longings
and so it's it's a trade-off and so some
people might know
my
creative longing is stronger than
wanting to have certain things right
right and being okay with that and i
know this society doesn't always honor
that i get that i understand um
[Music]
as a woman who doesn't have children so
i understand how it can be looked at as
you're selfish or whatever and and i'm
okay with that and and
just i think that that's a curse a lot
of creative people bear you know
is is is it okay that i haven't done
these certain things
but i have something else that i i'm
chasing or i'm actively doing right and
just being okay with that right
guess it's up to the individual no
you're
absolutely absolutely
yeah i feel that
i i
feel like you know i have to now do this
i have to
achieve some sort of
success and when i say success i don't
mean like millions of dollars and you
know arms full of gold trophies yeah i
just want to make a living
in this business you know i want to
make a living as a screenwriter
and i feel that if i can do that then
the sacrifices definitely would have
been worth it
so
what does sacrifice mean to you that's a
great question
when i think about
what i've just said
i don't know if if
sorry sorry that's okay what what if i i
text you hey jay we're all at tj
friday's right now for happy hour can
you can you meet us there
probably say no
sure
got these great potato skins and we're
having drinks look i love potato skins
and i i love alcoholic beverages
but
if if i'm working on something
or if i
feel that i have the time to
to go to fridays could probably spend
that time
outlining or rewriting
you know i feel like so much of my time
is already taken up by
endeavors that
aren't really serving you know this this
dream you know i've got to
give hours to the day job and you know i
still have to just take care of myself
you know life things um
and so the little bit of free time that
that i have
i often feel like i need to dedicate
that to the craft
um i'm sure every once in a while i
like to you know have fun but
[Laughter]
but i would probably decline i would
probably decline an invitation to just
hang out
i know that makes me sound like i'm not
a fun individual i promise i am
[Laughter]
you know i think after you now
you can get some of that out of your
system after a while i mean i can only
speak for myself and sometimes you see
that some of that goes nowhere
and then
what's really worth it to you we only
have so much time right right so
i don't think that sounds bad but you
know i'm like i said you know i'm making
i'm making those efforts uh
had like a fantastic like overseas trip
with my friends earlier this year you
know we thought things were
safe and safe enough to go you know it
was a blast you know and and some of
them i hadn't seen in years and it was
great to see them and
and see their families and and hang out
with the you know with them so so i'm
making that effort i i am making that
effort
sure and then there's the whole like
john sales you know you've got to go out
and have a life before you can write
about one kind of thing and
that's understandable but i know
especially here and i'm sure in new york
as well maybe other cities it's easy to
get caught up with a lot of that oh
definitely you know especially when
you're younger and then all the dramas
that go around with that and you know
some of that
it doesn't go anywhere so yeah it's
making that decision yeah
do you feel like you've sacrificed
enough or is there more you could be
doing
i mean there's definitely more
i could be doing
but i
i do think that i've sacrificed plenty
it's about
trying to find that balance i guess you
know when
when can i take the break when can i
attend to other things
and
just be confident that
the screenwriting pursuit will take care
of itself you know to trust that things
are happening the way that they should
uh
which will then you know allow me to
have that breather to have drinks and
fridays and potato skins
or to you know take a trip you know with
the family
um
right i mean you know there's there's
some people that go on these like sort
of almost like monastic retreats
within their own lives to work on
whatever and they shut everything out
and maybe that is necessary they're
they're less like tech monk and they
can't be bothered and they're doing
whatever they're you know or or none or
whatever
and
i don't know i don't know how long does
that really pay off
i i wonder because i've i've done that
you know i've taken those periods where
i've kind of shut everyone and
everything out so that i can
say work on a script you know get
something done
and
while you know i'm usually happy with
the work that i produced or what have
you
yeah was that
was
that sacrifice really worth it was
taking that period and shutting every
everyone and everything out
wasn't really worth it
i don't know
what about the sort of hunter s thompson
approach it's like gonzo
journalism where you're
hanging out with motorcycle gangs and
try you know infiltrate you know
going on the road with a band as a
roadie or you know just like
would would you ever go on on sort of
the the very opposite to come up with a
story idea i could see myself doing
something like that yeah
but because you know i i understand what
the goal is like
hanging out at fridays i don't i don't
see you know what the goal is i mean
aside from you know having fun and
getting drunk and you know potato skins
i don't really see
you know that
turning into something that would
benefit the pursuit
but as you mentioned with the hunter s
thompson example you know i could see
okay this is going to turn into a story
this will turn into a script this will
spark you know uh
an idea of something you know a creative
endeavor that is worth pursuing so yeah
sure i can see myself doing something
like that